[Musique]
nous avons le grand plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui sur le site des
clayes-sous-bois d'atos principal site
de r&d en france d'atos une délégation
québécoise complètement centrée sur les
technologies quantiques donc des
investisseurs des start up et des
membres des clusters québécois non ça
c'est très important pour atos d'avoir
cette capacité de rencontrer des
écosystèmes étrangers en quantum puisque
atos a commencé à développer une
stratégie quantique de pelé années 2016
développé un simulateur un simulateur
quantique se prépare à développer un
supercalculateur hybride quantique et
dans ce cadre là nous recherchons des
partenaires et nous voulons également
participer à la grande aventure du
cantique c'est en fait une véritable
industrie qui était en train de se
développer donc ces écosystèmes sont
très précieux à nos yeux et nous permet
de développer des partenariats et
d'acquérir une connaissance de beaucoup
plus fine de ce qui se fait dans le
monde dans les technologies cantique
[Musique]
des cantiques telle initiative qui
regroupe l'écosystème des sciences et
technologies quantiques du québec l'idée
derrière la mission est pourquoi on est
ici aujourd'hui pour en fait créer des
collaborations et même amplifié qui a
déjà été fait par le passé on l'a déjà
eu quelques collaborations avec la
france en termes de science et
technologie quantique on est très
heureux d'être ici aujourd'hui pour
visiter finalement l'écosystème de paris
saclay en passant par atos et en allant
visiter les laboratoires de ses 2 m
quand même temps le profité pour
rencontrer quelques stades et faire un
peu de mariages avec des start up du
québec et des startups françaises
[Musique]